[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everybody be : 360 live pre-show starts
now
now thank you
hey guys yo welcome to the conan 360
live pre-show presented by AT&T again
I'm your host Moses storm and now your
other host it's now Moses storm Chris
ready we are here at the roof or the
Spreckels theater in this town comic-con
we're in 360 so look around our set
looks like the saddest scene cut from
the live-action remake of Moana that's
what it looks like right now
too soon for a reboot yes
actually all of this Tiki set was very
cheap because it's all left over from Ja
Rule's failed fire festival yeah whoever
thought the rule would disappoint Jim
what it was that's a bang at the shop
that's a shot you'll know shots coming
because great night right in those eyes
of yours so we have a great show because
we're counting down to the Conan show
we're just minutes away from the Conan
tapings so we're gonna be with you guys
for this whole hour
that's exactly right we have some great
people that want to talk to when the
torches Janet Varney she's the voice of
The Legend of Korra
that's gonna be dope can't wait yeah we
also got the cast of Teen Wolf cool oh
yeah and if you don't know what team
will face it so it's the show but a wolf
that was a baby at first and became a
teen and has like angsting yeah prom and
all that this so there's no human beings
in the show we're just gonna bring up a
series of husky dogs with acne yeah it's
Teen Wolf and we are definitely lying
about that there's a cast full cast and
they can't wait to get out on their roof
yeah man we also have an exclusive conan
tour the obvious prat room of this prop
master builder correct bill told the
comment section loves that bill till he
is captain understand what follows him
on vine
yeah our vine and if you know if you see
coming up here you know that we're
second definitely fire now it's gone eh
guys what's going on man I gotta tell
you man it's the big big night here Game
of Thrones Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones I got the questions I'm gonna be
asking them okay I should pay the
questions you get what's your show about
I've never
I've never seen it never seen it really
I didn't think it was popular yeah so no
I'm a big game of Thrones fan so this is
this is what I'm excited about right for
sure and just a quick note very bright
up here on the roof yeah didn't bring my
sunglasses what's on the way up I Chris
Hayes who's our IT guy I grabbed his
glasses and I've never won okay we have
no idea you do look like a downed
Vietnam pilot right now just internet
let me know this is a horrible mistake
registration when you look at me Pachi
is that popular I don't you just hear a
chopper in your head there's no I'm just
no one out there right now out there you
guys you premiered that car for the
flaming see finally gas his own car what
happens to all this this memorabilia
well actually the car I actually drove
the car around Comic Con today in the
full Conan suit that turned out to be I
really did that and you might be seeing
that on the show tonight but what I
didn't take into account is that it
raises your body temperature I would
think and I'm not even kidding maybe
about 80 degrees the suit and you're
driving around San Diego in an open car
so I got back to my hotel room and three
guys pulled the suit off me and I had a
you have to wear a unitard underneath it
to help get a suit on that thing came
off and it's imagine dunking long
underwear in water like a basin of water
I think I lost about eight pounds is
water weight like a body con it is a
body condom you use a protection coating
and I and I appreciate that I do good
message Paul you boys and girls out
there yes there's no Maya hey whatever
happened with jeremiad you ever find out
Jeremiah lost his kids not not did you
at court oh he lost them in court
document you not taking care your kids
you know what I love is that you have
proof against him in 360 300
great way to remind people that we are
circling if you ever want to feel like
you're in a Fight Club in full clothes
yeah with a guy in like a Lacoste shirt
I like what you're wearing this is nice
you got sort of a Speed Racer thing
going wandering around we do shoot at
high noon guys really cool you know I
want to say this our our final show but
I do sincerely thank you you guys have
been really funny you've been great
you've made this thing your own
seriously I that is a sincere thank you
for helping us out No thank you no I
have a sincere thank you back okay take
something and you can tell me if this is
creepy or flattering I like I'm gonna go
with I'm gonna go with the baby already
said creepy I got like a disclaimer at
the beginning okay very good
right okay so a huge fan of your show oh
thank you dear old boy and again was not
allowed to watch your show right growing
up so I was like I have to watch the
show this is everything I honestly love
about comedy and all I want to do yeah
so what I did because we were
homeschooled so I couldn't just go to a
friend's house to watch your show is I
made my mom signed me up for this
program called a Becca and what they do
is they send students like videotapes of
actual classrooms so you can feel like
you're in cool last room and I only
signed up for that so I could get a
tv/vcr
in my room so I could secretly record
your show
I like that at 11:00 at night dedication
that is really nice and I'm so glad he
got to tell that story because he's been
telling me that story in preparation
they holy [ __ ] that's six but that took
he really went the extra mile a lot of
pumps out there yeah grew up on the show
and they could just watch it whenever
they wanted you it was it's more
impressive what you and I told my older
brothers that I was that I was doing
this and I was like it's so cool cuz I
just like secretly record the show right
and they're like yeah we always heard
you messing around with VHS tapes we
don't know that's what you're doing we
thought you just found one of our porn
tapes and you were just furiously math
no no and you were furiously
masturbating but you were you were doing
it to my one of my old classic shows
from the late 90s yes yeah a man is late
[Laughter]
yeah that's what it does you guys this
is been a joy
how what have you learned let's might
touch you on the shoulder yeah man you
know imagine what have you learned what
have you guys learned how to get you -
what have you learn they're like young
Jedi's what do they learn from the old
man I have learned that doing jokes in
us in a slight breeze on a roof is not
my favorite but it ain't the worst right
right you know there is an old theory
and I'm gonna credit this to Dana Carvey
Dana Carvey once time a comedy needs
compression he told me this to me years
ago it needs to be in a small space or
else that so that the humor can bounce
around yeah and then we put you guys on
a rooftop and what we could do is we
could next time seal the walls because
I'll sometimes you'll say something
funny but it just blows right into the
carpet yeah yeah a lot of my stuff just
blew away yeah but it's being found by
sailors out at sea and they need that
yeah guys are just chuckling I think
Demetri Martin said any place that would
be good in a fire it would be would be
horrible and a fire would be great right
bad boy you're good for coming yeah I
like a great that's a great better learn
that than tap and roll that's more
important don't you take it it just
looks stupid by your burn alive yeah
here's a complication tonight yeah we
have all these people from Game of
Thrones I think it's like 10 people and
it's the kind of thing where you have to
say you have to know they're the actor's
name but then you also have to be able
to say as says blab joy you you know and
and that's when it starts to make my
brain explode and I was getting a
headache preparing for the interview so
much so that I bought this little thing
of Tylenol and I've been eating these
things like crazy yeah just because your
mind is in zero water to just chewing
them down I just chew them down I don't
take any water and um I just tried
trusting that those are tylenol right
someone put some pills in there well
look look at Rick and I don't know you
don't need any because you've had kind
of show forever but if you need more
time to think of names you can have them
answer every question one word at a time
that's a good wedge it out we're getting
all of you
so much everything is so long right so
we've been telling the guests to put
periods at the end of every single word
yes great this is a great experience for
you there's nothing like just being
thrown out there 360 degrees you can't
hide now and look at this when do you
ever see Conan O'Brien wearing a
full-body suiting they just cut off
where the ankles are no this is really
horrifying I want to apologize I just I
had to get into San Diego spirits where
were these shorts today look at that
giant birthmark I've had that since I
was a kid right there and look at my
mother it's wider
yeah that's the one part where I get
whiter I match from when my mom told me
I had to take out the trash when I was
like 12 so I grabbed both bags and I was
wearing shorts it was a summer time and
one of the bags slammed up against my
leg and it had a open tunafish can top
in it and it went chunk right into my
leg right down to the bone I want you to
think about that and that's all get in
really close your hand all right hey yes
yeah troll us now chat wait giving chat
the power that he always wanted right
don't do that even be we're learning
without your anger he has no power
that's right guys let's hug it out this
is the worst use of I've just been told
that AT&T stock has plummeted a full
eighty point yeah so I should return
this shirt is what I heard you got to go
okay they're literally packing up right
around us I'm going downstairs to see
The Game of Thrones gang yes gonna be
dope and then there's gonna be some
crazy off-the-hook party tonight right
yeah I'm reckon thank you in person Yeah
right he's got a little beats you
get invited you got a question oh I
definitely got my circling the floors
trying to get a soft invite we'll get
you in there yeah I'll see you guys have
a great show and we'll check in with you
when we xxx you on the stage no you're
not to speak to me again okay that makes
it makes a lot of sense yeah no no
you'll see this was your payment you get
to keep all of this fake grass oh I'm
not gonna do it big white man said I'm
going I'm gonna walk away from you now
for a really long time all right
virtue allottee handsets because you're
rich and don't have to pay bills you can
watch code and walk away very slowly
still walking away he's still he's still
waiting milking it he's just gonna look
true he became the man he is he wouldn't
leave you guys later
can you see my okay you guys are
watching the conan 360 live pari show
yes so we're gonna have some guests on a
little bit yep game with those casters
you've also heard yeah we have some
coming in yeah yeah yeah I will be
downstairs playing some games I'll
actually show you right now where I'll
be playing some games that we don't have
some cameras in the lobby to go that
Lobby camera see right there you see
people coming in for the show I'll be
down there playing a game called a build
a better hero so go ahead send your hero
names in that don't exist in the chat I
will use if the cast arrives we're just
gonna yank you out of there because Game
of Thrones cast those Cavs will be
coming through the entrance the alley
right yeah this is the artists entrance
that's exactly I was down there the
other day and it was a mess it was the
Kingsmen cast there's people screaming
on one side you're trying to get like
one question in it's a it's it's it's
like the creek it's like the craziest
thing and then we also have the stage
mic where you'll be seeing the Conan
show you see people lined up in there
look at everybody
the audience is sad people are ready to
go and they just sit nothing warms up a
crowd like just sitting for an hour and
then we are back to us up here on the
roof we could be seeing some inner masks
out of the way just in time before yeah
you did yeah yeah as a problem you know
it's one of the last days where at the
end of the week
people are smelling bad and we're
drinking heavily so much so not a dairy
based alcohol
I'm doing a ton of milk period ha so a
little bit we're gonna take a look at
the Batmobile Museum it's at the Warner
Brothers lot so home base for Conan is
the Burbank WB lot yeah and if you visit
there now there's all the Batmobiles of
ever or on display there so we're gonna
take a 360 tour of that right now
hey Conan 360 live this is John Coronas
from Warner Brothers Studio tower
Hollywood I'm currently inside of the
picture car vault or as I like to call
it the Batcave I'm gonna show you around
some of my absolute favorite things
follow me over to this Batmobile here
now what you see is the Batmobile from
Batman Forever
that's where Val Kilmer played Bruce
Wayne and Batman crazy fact the radio in
here is stuck forever unseals kiss from
a rose it's the only thing to plays
inside of the car we also have the bikes
from Batman and Robin we have Robins red
bird we have batgirls bat blade we also
have the original the number one hero
car from Batman 1989 Michael Keaton's
car now that's of course the one that
Tim Burton originally directed and from
the Nolan trilogy the bat statue it's
probably kind of hard to see the entire
thing but he's got no pants on who would
make a statue like that
now clearly some of the absolute most
imposing things in this exhibit look
behind you the tumblers from the Dark
Knight trilogy now this is where
Christopher Nolan took over directing
and you can really see the realistic
aspect of Batman these are the real deal
they really run and they are the
originals they have Chevy 350 small
block v8 engines in there so Bruce Wayne
while you know he hasn't really
philanthropic guy apparently the
environment in terms of gas mileage not
on his list of priorities and that's
fine but you see the camouflage tumbler
really make its its appearance in the
Dark Knight Rises
but the black tumbler really carries its
way through the Batman Begins and the
Dark Knight but behind me we're gonna
take a closer look at the Joker car here
we are inside of the Joker's car what an
experience look at this thing
we got velour all over the roof it's on
the panels it's like blinged out to the
max there's Gold everywhere gold shifter
I don't know if you can see down there
but there are custom Joker mats there's
like snake skin everywhere this thing
has to be a monster to actually clean
but look at this diamond-encrusted
steering wheel surprisingly good for
grip I can see why he has that it's
amazing and you know reinforced roof
because at some point it's bound to
happen somebody dressed up as a bat is
gonna land right on the roof punch a
hole through the thing rip the Joker out
tight quarters - I can see he gets
really nuzzled up - Harley Quinn it
makes it really easy for a romantic date
night you know man I got to get me one
of these that's gonna do it for me again
everybody thank you for checking out
some of my favorite things but we
encourage you to come see for yourself
so join us book your tickets at WB
studio tor.com what else can I say about
this exhibit besides the fact that it's
the bane of my existence don't just
bring your nuclear family because this
place is the bomb I am so sorry oh and
welcome back to the conan 360 live show
presented by AT&T and chris and i are
here with the cast of Teen Wolf how are
you
we got Charlie Carver khylin Rhambo
Hayes Cody Christian Christian the one
guy I actually butchered his name they
look like a Christian boy band now this
is the last season Teen Wolf and you
guys have the panel earlier earlier in
the week and here's like a pretty
emotional panel because it's kind of
like a goodbye for everyone
what was that like versus the other
years I mean it was crazy for me this is
my third year being would have come to
comic-con and the energy the last two
years was just through the roof man you
walked off every response every answer
was so engaging you couldn't you
couldn't think straight with the amount
of sweating but this year was different
and I think we can all attest to it was
very sentimental it was almost as if
this this undertone of appreciation of
everybody like you know really being
present because they know that the
goodbye was coming it was the thing is
actors really thrive on applause and in
Hall H it like oh my god I finally got
an audience of 6,000 people to try out
some of my jokes and it was like every
time you don't clap for an actor a fairy
does and up all the PAS before we go on
we make them applaud us who was like to
maybe break down on the panel maybe day
one every episode he's been in I
honestly I felt like I was watching
something sacred yeah just all of them
just it was it was real emotions up
there for us I'm sure for the fans too
yeah it's also testament to the show hey
guys I have to go now
remember I have the same earpiece in he
did not need to leave him so sorry about
that all I'm doing that girl AJ house of
Teen Wolf of like what camp
what house went house stark of course
how start right words are blurred what I
do look a little like Joffrey I could
definitely see a strong Joffrey vibe
ohoo Joffrey King Johnson horrible
Lannister he's the word now we're just
plugging other shows yeah I know we are
we should get back to you guys yes ten
episodes and that's premiering on the
31st 31st if you're subbing m'lady
Sundays oh you're on Sundays now eight
great plug for your birthday definitely
got that so I got people screaming I got
you yeah so you guys do a lot of night
shoots on Teen Wolf Kozlov it's like
outside who's been to the first person
to like lose their mind on sake because
night shoots gonna get a little oh well
yeah I remember
Shelly's the first one to take a nap for
sure every time yeah we're in the woods
she always has her a little like
sleeping bags you can move she's
efficient yeah the first one I get way
too caffeinated because I think that you
might handle it but then I can't like
those double shot espresso those add up
yeah yes or is like I think I calm down
any anybody that has to do naked stuff
you had to do that one time you didn't
like just said it wasn't taped at all no
shame around don't take that kind of
stuff every time I did do one short with
Kody many years ago and I was the nude
one no I had a little sock and a little
since one of these James Franco inspired
projects weirdest thing in my life and I
was just trying to keep on track with
Kody it's just you walk in the camp yeah
we're gonna cut down right up to the
artists camp where we have Gwendolyn
arriving from Game of Thrones right at
the artist cam she's signing autographs
so you guys helped here with the cast of
Teen Wolf
hi and we got Chris get settled does
that work Chris took off - that's where
Chris Torrio's hey Chris hey Chris I
don't know if you can hear me or not
what's up you can't sure know same
things gonna happen today castigated
rugs next year once you're in your last
season people just walk out mid
interview and he's walked directly past
me because they're being rushed in like
crazy I'm gonna see if I could talk to
brittle enough man hey Gwendolyn hey
Gwendolyn you you might say hi to Conan
360 she's so tough
how are you doing hi I'm really Wow how
are you good I know you have so many
fans what's your favorite part about
this about this about comic-con
it's incredible to be in the same room
with people that are loved the work you
know and you get to see them and
hopefully give a little bit back to them
that's amazing you're amazing a huge fan
enjoy your time here enjoy all these
fans we'll see you inside
she was super dope man he was correct
she was crazy nice right she's so
beautiful this is we're gonna play a
game later you guys you have tickets all
right well I'm gonna be giving away some
tickets all right good show
we're to see who else is popping out
here man's crazy we got like a nice
three-second talk with wind Elaine that
was amazing
and she still signed a man she's still
out here signing fans a posters signing
it
next is the greatest person this is a
very tough this is very tog the darling
short turns and usual oh oh yeah so we
got we got to talk to the big guy
this is Dumbledore man y'all know y'all
know he's I adjusted a rock so I got
asked to wear his shoes are from those
shoes are crazy you excited I'm hella
excited while we wait right now we're
gonna go ahead and throw back to Moses
Moses what's going on up there man hey
Chris I'm up here with the cast of Teen
Wolf hanging out and I just want to get
that out there so it's premiering let's
get this right July Sunday 30 July 30th
at 8:00 p.m.
wait 9 and your birthday is also coming
that's all plug our birthdays as well
January 8th July 7 my son sign is in
Taurus
I'm Ali and I'm a cancer as well guys
thank you so much for joining us on this
very hectic mess of a show it's all
right a cast of Teen Wolf July 30th
that's Sunday watch it on MTV we're
going back down to Chris Chris to me
have you done that the artists entrance
thank you guys so much for joining us
and we're back this is like true live
show fashion
I never know I won't camera until I know
and we got Chris right there man signing
autographs better known as Dumbledore in
the show Game of Thrones and this is
crazy man there's so much so many cast
members so many black lubbers pulling up
you never know who's gonna pop out here
man I might go ahead and play a game
with a fan right now
and give away some tickets maybe after
Christian goes inside because it's is
crazy
hey Chris [ __ ] that's not gonna work
I'm not aggressive enough as a person
I'm not gonna run up on him while we may
for more hey well what's your name yeah
Alexi where you from I'm from San Diego
okay it was what's your favorite part
about Comic Con Christian and Christian
say I said how Dakota 360 i conan 360
we're so happy to have you man what's
your favorite part about Comic Con oh
god everything the people moan the
people who are incredible yeah I always
love to be here man we're big fan of you
man that you've made the world cry on
that show so go ahead and and I'll have
your fans and enjoy that was crazy
everybody so nice from that show man for
real
everybody so nice and I'm being snapchat
it and talking to y'all things are
happening all right back to you are you
trying to get some tickets to come see
the show you have to do anything you
said to play one game with me okay
all right now we have a nice swag bag
brought to you by AT&T all right and
when it'll be a bunch of stuff in there
if we can see this back see this bag it
has if you hold this microphone laughs
anyway we got a beach there you got a
bad within the bag
you got a Conan hat they can't see any
of this and then they got they got two
tickets to see tonight's show BAM right
there
over there all right now you have you
have time to win this right now by
answering me some Game of Thrones trivia
are you ready for this how much do you
know about Game of Thrones how much do
you know about Game of Thrones okay you
ready yes all right who is bran stark
named after his uncle his aunt his
grandfather or his grandmother no does
anybody know the answer grandfather no
she just said grandpa hold on oh no I
could you know says you're right what's
your name
Ali where are you from our Colorado
River Colorado that's amazing it's just
is this your friend Ryan what's your
name
Olivia Olivia well I hope you guys enjoy
the conus show they know how to yell
that's amazing I'm gonna give you
another chance though I got you she
stole that one from you Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh Jess all right I have to give you
another chance because I told you I
would you slipped up but this is your
chance I and I vow that you ant acts one
person behind you if you need the help
all right all right here we go
you see ah which of the following is not
a face of the seven the maiden the widow
the mother the stranger the window the
window is correct
[Applause]
hey you better take him in there he
helps you a hotel you away from dcae
she's handing you a bag
[Applause]
you you okay what's your name
Natalia Natalia oh that's a dump
accident love you are you ready to play
this game at those trivia yeah
who has Petra Baelish loves since he was
a child
Catelyn Stark are you sure you don't
want to hit a hit you own is it it
sounds too stark I'm not gonna argue a
child it says you Rob i'ma give you no
chance okay who cuts off Jaime
Lannister's hand
Rickard Rickard Karstark Roose Bolton
Lackey Jaime Lannister his name is luck
you right go ahead get these tickets I
got to your circus and this is your mom
yes tomorrow oh the one that was yelling
at me
she's right well she got you good job
alright we go see you in there okay no
swear I only have so many tickets sir
wait wait alright wait what the Yemeni
don't have anything what do I have work
they'll have no work but if they've won
all the tickets minutes pandemonium out
here Randy Game of Thrones fans and the
game of throne cash is so cool
do we have more people pull it out right
now I need some more people pulling up
yeah hey y'all yelling you're yelling
tonight man
anybody in my shooting back up to the
roof what is happening I'm just going to
come here keep talking to people
huh nothing I was just talking wait wait
so what's your name
Diego Diego where you from from Mexico
from Mexico you came I went myself to be
here you gotta get your yelling right
yeah Wow yeah you in America we just be
real loud about things this is my chance
to be to be to yellow
yeah you better yellow everybody yeah
Widow yeah we're having so much fun out
here man we're gonna go ahead and cut
back to Moses Moses what's going on to
that roof man hey Chris yeah still up
here on the roof we're gonna be checking
back in with Chris in a little bit he's
down at the artist entrance and helping
surprise and delight people with those
AT&T gift bags that are filled with all
sorts of Conan memorabilia and he's
giving out like tickets down there as
we're seeing cast members arrived now in
case you missed any of the moments from
the Conan Comic Con shows we have some
of our favorite moments that we're gonna
show you right now presented to our
presented to you by our friends from
AT&T I think you see Chris and roses
Andy I do there they are they're right
in front of me it's like I can touch
them yeah they're on the rooftop right
now and I think there they are yes yes
[Applause]
yeah it's beautiful what a sad sack we
built for them yeah yeah it looks yeah
it's a rejected outhouse from Jurassic
Park yeah see here as always comic-con
is incredibly crowded isn't it amazing
it is so crowded here's how crowded
comic-con is I had to wait in line for
three hours just to host this show yes
I'm just waiting
how did it feel is my question
Luke when you boundary with your father
he cut off my hand
I sure would like you to use those I
feel statements I feel bad I feel sad I
feel I feel like flipping you off right
now okay could have been more affected I
don't know why you didn't use the the
good hand
[Applause]
but there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get there right
away you give it a little too much let's
take it back just say this bank robbery
we get there's a bank robbery going on
right now you need to get they're still
not satisfied but okay I'll get that
geez okay hold on hold on there's
nowhere for this foot to go shut the
door this doesn't really instill fear
does it who sits in this this is like
the Kevin Hart mobile
[Applause]
welcome back to the Conan Live 360
pre-show presented by AT&T again those
were some of our favorite highlights
from the past Conan shows I liked how
the first one was just a clip of me that
is my favorite I watched those till I
fall asleep and right now we're gonna
cut to our stage 360 cam where we got
the audience that are had seated in
there just before Conan is about to come
out this is really cool look I was in
there earlier for the rehearsals and
it's gonna be a really good show there's
a special surprise guest that's stopping
by the show we got to see that rehearsal
and we also got to see them wheeled that
car out the other night that was pretty
cool to see and we got to see Conan
warming up with some of these monologue
jokes I didn't know this but Conan
actually warms up with the guitar he's
essentially playing guitar the entire
time and it makes like a really cool
vibe for the rehearsal so it just feels
less stiff in there and we're back up
here on the roof again you're watching
the Conan 360 live show presented by
AT&T where we are waiting for the
arrival of some of the more some more of
the Game of Thrones cast members and we
got some videos to show you guys from
some more highlights from the shows and
some special pieces and we have an
interview coming up with a very special
guest and we're never gonna go down to
Chris who's in the lobby with some fans
Chris do I have you down in the lobby I
am chilling what's going on man we are
here with a couple of fans of comic-con
and and they yell very quietly and it's
very adorable what we're gonna do right
now is we're gonna play a game called
build a better superhero
I had the chat earlier send me some
names of some superheroes that do not
exist and they're gonna just themselves
up with that given 30 seconds and if
they can tell me a superpower and the
origin story that I'm impressed with
I'll give them a bag of goodies
presented by AT&T now who's ready to
play this game you wanna go first
your hands shot up real fast all right
come on around here come on around here
everybody make noise for while she goes
right
oh yeah that's not it very lonely
how are you doing what's your name my
name is Lauren Lauren where you from San
Diego here in San Diego so Knack far now
what's your favorite part about
comic-con is actually coming to Conan
I've been here for the last two years
and it's super super awesome and I enjoy
it and I'm really happy to be here again
well we love having you but the love for
Conan will not help you win this bag of
goodies you got to be creative are you
ready for that I think so all right I'm
gonna go down to my handy-dandy chat
right here and see what name I get your
superhero is fist magnet fist magnet
this magnet which sounds terrible but
we're gonna go with it anyway fist
magnet you have 30 seconds to build your
superhero are you ready yes I got it go
30 seconds yeah I'm not counting I don't
not have one counter on me but I can
feel when 30 seconds is up thirty mode
seconds up how does that is that how
time works 25000 she got okay she got
some silky bliss a very silky blanket
that's nice yes okay ten more seconds
plus 15 seconds that's 15 seconds could
have just said that no it's not 25 here
we go are you ready are you done in time
okay look at this this is you like a
Statue of Liberty ready for bed and I
like that so much fist magnet what is
your superpower my superpower is to rig
any election in the United States whoo
so you're just there a mild exited job
and what's your origin story I came from
here right here in the USA I was born in
Texas and I believe the USA is the best
place in the world and no one else
should come here no one else to come in
that sounds familiar fifth segment I
feel like you already have a built-in
audience to your superhero and you know
what I think that that is a pretty
topical outfit and I like the fact you
do the accent so I think you'll win this
bag let's go ahead and give her a bag
atsc goodies this is presented by a cnc
man we have a bunch of cool stuff in
there thank you for playing put all that
stuff down because you can't keep it
girl you can't gig you yeah you get on
out of here
yeah this hat is awesome and you had a
gun I didn't see the gun in there it was
hiding as you should do guns yeah you
know what you are who you you are who
you want to be I don't know what that
means
we're just saying stuff down here who's
ready to play this game you ready to
play come on up back here give it up for
y'all there's only one of us down here
giving it up my man how you feeling
pretty good how you feeling I'm great
let's go what's your name re re where
you from I'm from San Diego oh man look
at a bunch of hometown heroes now what's
your favorite part about Comic Con my
favorite part about Comic Con sure I
said it first but I love Conan that's my
favorite thing to come to that's the
most thing I look why I look for two
most out of anything well that's amazing
we're so glad to have you here are you
ready to hear what your character is I
think so
alright the chat has spoken and the chat
says the garlic finger man the garlic
finger man you ready go I got to get out
of way she is really going oh she's
going for the green gloves all right she
needs protection that's a good thing
that's a solid choice taking a little
long 22 seconds not counting at all here
we go
oh nice sombrero that that's a that's a
strong choice okay oh and we got the
easy mask on boom you gotta hide that
identity you already know how it is five
four three two one it done Wow garlic
finger man I like the fact that you have
your gloves like oh they had them
he'll love that so he can see it now
okay so what is your superpower um your
soy garlic finger and my superpower is
making very spicy but like not chili
spicy like garlic spicy food and it like
attacks my enemies from this stomach out
so you gotta cook first so you gotta be
like hey enemy hold on one second spring
a little salt I like use any friendly
first I'm like hey come over so it's
like a rope-a-dope situation okay that's
dope what's it what's the origin story
um I was born in Mexico obviously
underneath a bed of garlic obviously
found from the ground someone found me
from my fingers sticking up and pulled
me up from there they say you were just
a human vegetable pretty much that's
amazing you know what that was very
complicated and I liked it and you took
my oj joke well so go ahead and give you
this 18c presented bag of goodies man
all right you go ahead put that down you
take that sombrero off you looked as
powerful as you felt I don't know what
I'm supposed to do with this you gonna
hold it you ready to play man come on up
come on over come on over man
we're having a bomb am giving out
somebody's prizes presented by AT&T and
we got one more guy coming here to play
the game what's your name it Joe Lopez
Joe opus Oh full name he wants you to
google him where you from
oh la la are you on the run you-you-you
thought about that look look what's your
favorite part about comic-con ah the
city it's beautiful what I love coming
here
yeah San Diego's dope did you take the
train I did isn't it beautiful beautiful
Jesus yeah we'll talk about it later
right now is about games player
it's about games right now we're gonna
build you to be here you ready yeah all
right I'm gonna go to the chat see what
the chat says hmm the iron
disappointment that is your superhero
are you ready 30 seconds on the clock
that doesn't exist go nobody seconds is
running man come on
the iron disappointment he's already
started with something very
disappointing looking and he's taking a
lot of time to get it on eat that is a
yeah he is channeling his character
alright okay okie took his hat off to
put on a character hat but he's figuring
out what had he wants to use BAM
alright he goes for the glitter around
the trim that's nice no oh no throw it
on there man you got ten more seconds
kind of yeah you're good okay time I'm
going to say you don't have a weapon the
iron disappointment well you know what
you are you nailed the look I think no
one should be proud of this ah
now what is your superpower I disappoint
people and my personal life and I kill
sometimes you know got to do it you be
running around I'm not a superior I'm a
villain
oh you super villain yeah you go around
just disappointing people sometimes
well that that yeah that sounds like
okay and what's the origin story of this
man um I was adopted foster home you
know all that stuff I don't want to go
too deep on my that's the point of the
game you got to go deep I don't know the
rules I'm disappointing you by not
giving you an X you know what man you
are challenging this character so where
I'm going and give you this bag I gotta
give you the bag
I gotta give you because it was a very
disappointed way to play this game but
you did it and you and you wit all the
way through it's brought to you by AT&T
enjoy all those grab bags man and you
guys enjoy your comic-con experience you
know I mean and that's it for me down
here your Moses was going on that roof
brother hey Chris Chris is down there
playing games with some fans helping
surprise and delight and presenting it
with some 80 gift bags got them on all
sorts of crazy costumes and everyone's
favorite culturally insensitive hat a
sombrero I got an answer for that let's
burn that hat all week we've been
checking in with Jordan shlonsky our
associate producer and tonight we're
gonna bid him a final farewell sorry
that sounds like he died so please enjoy
this last installment of conversations
all right next question
for Facebook Rebecca Eleanor Pfeiffer
asks why v-necks what do you have
against round collared shirts Rebecca on
Facebook is asking me why I don't wear
what we call crew neck t-shirt so you
can call them round collar yes if you
want a more convoluted way to describe
it but maybe that blame goes to Rebecca
and not you maybe I'm being unfair and
situation
Rebecca those are called crew neck
shirts with all due respect and I'm
wearing one right now I also wear
v-necks at times it's really a question
of releasing heat
okay now the human body's internal core
temperature is 98.6 degrees as we all
know even though nothing else around us
is that temperature that means that we
are raising our own core temperature and
expending energy and doing so that
energy normally comes from the food that
we eat we also sometimes if we cover
ourselves with too many clothes or a
jacket that's too thick we may say this
makes me hot in fact the jacket or the
blanket doesn't make you hot as much as
it prevents you from releasing your own
heat you understand your body internally
is 98.6 degrees my responsibility to
stay at an externally comfortable
temperature is to release that heat into
the environment if I'm covered it
impedes that release which could be
beneficial in a cold climate in that
case you don't want to release your heat
because you can't make the heat quickly
enough to counteract the cold of the
environment however in a hotter
environment you do want to release that
heat and the way you do that is by
exposing as much of your skin as
possible to the environment and short
sleeve shirts are a way to do that
shorts are a way to do that and a v-neck
t-shirt is another way to do that by
exposing the area of my neck to the
environment I am releasing more heat so
it's not a fashion choice
it's a is a temperature choice for you
it is a your it's a it's a body choice
it's a it's a physiological rather than
fashion based I think the fit of a
t-shirt is a very critical thing I think
that way okay well in the same way that
the simplest pastas are the most
difficult to cook the simplest articles
of clothing are often the most complex
when it turns
when it comes to the subtleties of them
and I think the fit of a t-shirt between
the shoulders the chest and the waist
that holy triumvirate is is a delicate
combination and of a certain brand fits
you you may not care whether it's a
crewneck or a v-neck
now can you if you will just cast your
eye your critical eye upon this t-shirt
yeah for sure I'm gonna do a quick
slow-motion turn what do you think about
this shirt you know even if you had
turned more quickly I would have had the
acuity to follow and make form an
opinion okay I'm gonna tell you that
first we need to talk about your body
before we talk about the shirt because
every shirt fits differently on
different bodies the question is how
well does that shirt fit your body and
what is the ratio between your chest
your waist and your shoulders I can tell
you that if I were to cast a critical
eye I would say it fits your waist very
well there's no excess material and
there's no excess bulk I would say that
it's but you don't have to raise your
hands to the side back that distorts the
shirt so I would say that with your arms
straight down it is a little tight in
the pectoralis Majoris I can see the
outline of your right nipple on my left
side I can tell you that in that sense
it's a little too tight your left pocket
distracts and possibly obscures that
nipple from being visible however the
shoulders seem to fit perfectly and and
all in all I'd say it's a valiant effort
the problem for you is the chest area
and again that's only a credit to you
and how much you've built those chest
muscles up if your chest muscles weren't
as strong the shirt would fit better but
at what price
see you're saying basically it's
shoulders good waist good nipples
visible now I'm not gonna say that's too
tight I'm gonna say that it's tight and
the nipples are visible if that's a
stylistic choice or a choice that you
prefer that's fine as well in that case
you have succeeded yes you know we all
have our own personal sense of style and
if that's how you choose to express
yours that's fine
I didn't want my nipple you know I don't
think about my nipples
so you're saying ideally your nipples
would not be visible well people looking
my nipple I mean I'm not saying people
are looking at it I'm only saying it's
visible people can decide what they
choose to look at if someone
to look at your elbow right or your I
mean
sternum why do men still have nipples
anyway like i don't use these nipples
for anything well you do understand that
human evolution is thousands of years
behind societal advances right I mean do
you understand why people have cravings
for food and cravings to need more than
they should for optimal health is based
on evolution a period when your next
meal wouldn't necessarily come for days
and you would need large amounts of
calories to support large bursts of
energy for fight or flight right well
okay all right well Jordan thank you so
much this was very enlightening in in
every possible way thank you for taking
us through your office and you guys you
can follow jordan on instagram and
snapchat at jordan shlonsky it's spelled
just like it sounds
and yeah always a pleasure thanks this
has been a mutually satisfying
experience see myself out
countdown yeah welcome back to the conan
360 live show presented by AT&T i'm
moses storm and i'm sitting down with
the lovely Janet Varney
welcome to the show so thank you so much
can I ask you how many people have made
a comic-con esque appropriate comment
about your name like is I'm a name for
comic-con yeah convention after this yes
all gets flipped around hunter fool
becomes a hardcore by wonderful just
some some C's will be parted absolutely
she's graces we couldn't afford to see
there's like a blue tarp that won't cut
in half fair enough it's very sad it's
very strict and religious I'm gonna call
Cirque de Soleil I feel like there's
probably some some old organza lying
down that we could flap and make it look
like oceans I feel like they would take
your call because they know you from The
Legend of Korra transition so terrible
move yeah Korra could bend the could
waterbend the seas apart well look out
Moses water that was the one who an
element that you can bend last airbender
he can bend all of them she can she can
yeah I myself for sure for many article
I really appreciate it but you've had a
great career away from you you did this
is really you know the Kim's just going
you start building up a nice solid
interview and I come here like we're
really about to get into our
relationship with our parents we were
like 48 minutes into a Marc Maron
interview that's about where we were
about to accuse me of something and I
was about to say I don't want you to
ever air this interviewed cast am i
incredible at these master yeah egg way
storm JB few egg ways I'm the store
that's our lower thirds there's no
we can't afford lower thirds I don't
even know thirds that well oh yeah no
not really
well imagine three of something okay and
imagine one of those you're great ah
thanks a lot I just gave you a degree
boom boom received omec know they would
give it bulls we see the Bulls you know
there's a lot of booming baby I don't
gonna worry you know I love using booms
on podcasts oh I'm sorry I was just
getting heavy that was that was it lying
I wanna be clear I do not have speaking
of mics went to high school with a guy
named Mike speak on that anyone watching
is like what is happening I guess what's
beautiful about this but anyway about
your pocket I have a podcast on the
Nerdist Network called the JV Club I
talk to famous people much more famous
than myself about their awkward high
school years it is very fun it is very
fun to listen to people who are
extremely attractive and successful
talking about pimples that I think for
some reason moves and touches us all
makes us all feel like we're equal I'm
an equalizer I'm nothing if not an
equalizer particularly when it comes to
pimples yeah and you share stories of
your embarrassing you just don't let
these celebrities see you ever had you
say I've always been incredible I always
just raised my eyebrow and go really
really like do you run out of stories
cuz I mean high school is only four
years for most of us and I had you're
bad at it yeah oh that's true and I knew
this was gonna happen so I did it for
seven proud years I don't I don't know
it's never I think there I feel like
there might be a podcast mean for me
that's I've probably said this on the
podcast before like I could have a
t-shirt that says that but often times I
say that as claim her to be safe and
then it turns out I've never said it
so thanks fans for knowing myself better
than I know myself
is there a zero story that sticks out in
your mind yeah they haven't heard it on
this show yeah I'm gonna say it right
now Alison Brie told a wonderful story
about how she wet her pants at like a
gymnastics competition this is what I'm
talking about
your life I love you so much more now
thank you for your salute you she's
fantastic
yeah great great place absolutely Amanda
people are willing to open up very
trustworthy face is that what it is yeah
let me ask you this does this trust
because this is usually what I do
oh that's you I would trust you the most
I crapped my pants when I was 12 years
old because I drank a diet Sunkist on my
birthday a whole two litre and I
wouldn't tell that to anyone but you're
very trustworthy face and he just said
hey I have to share when I was 16 years
old I jumped out of a second-story
window and sprained both my ankles at
the same time and still kept running
away really where were you running from
I was I told my prayers I'm done I'm out
of here
I didn't tell him that I left him a note
and I jumped out the window waited for
them to read the note and then he backed
out of the way reading that right yeah
and I had to keep on running away
because I couldn't think of a logical
story yeah that's who in the waking up
like what happened your ankles like oh I
had a I was falling in my sleep in and
they got real you know I can't I don't
know how to so I just kept running away
and then my dad found me as soon as I
got to the house cuz I only had one
friend I am calling you hobbles from
here on out have a new sweet nickname
for you hobble hobbles voice of The
Legend of Korra yeah true that is a show
that is no longer on the show right
promoting is IFC's stand against evil
with me and Johnse mckinley you probably
know her from scrubs yeah like every
awesome movie there ever was and that's
a show again on IFC that premieres our
second season premieres November 1st and
against Sheriff it's very unrealistic
guys I gotta talk about demons tell her
all of your secrets again you're
watching the coded 360 live show what
are we throwing to right now huh what
are we thought
oh you know what we are throwing to
right now we're throwing to the Konan
taking the tour the proper room with the
prop master himself yeah props to the
prop master right yeah that's 60 live
Conan O'Brien here this is pretty cool
we're in the prop room at Warner
Brothers stage 15 this is where all our
props exist pretty cool I mean
everything some of this stuff I think
goes back to the late night show
anything you can think of we have it
here anything from sketches to weird
comedy bits and there's built all the
prop master hey Bill
hey clone how's it going good okay this
is the worst interview I've ever had
bill tell me what any of these props go
back to the old late night agent we have
to turn those all in when things blew up
with NBC know we've got stuff we got
stuff from late night here's one of my
favorites oh my god check this out our
Jesus inspirational with cockfighting
right this is the thing we did that got
us in a lot of trouble on late-night I
was an inspirational figurine set of
Jesus at a cockfight with some kids I
don't know if you can see that but um
it's just that's gonna get us in trouble
again cuz we showed it oh my god here he
is look who's back here yes yes and here
he is without his head but yes I'm from
the nineties - check it out all kinds of
stuff Larry King this is a Larry King
doll that dates back to the old days
comedy who is comedy what's that missing
his glass missing his glasses we got to
find those anyway all kinds of stuff
here this looks like a bong it's also
Poseidon I think yep how is this gonna
be used for a comedy bit are we done
with it we're doing it okay perfect all
right
fake bagels I don't know why oh my god
there's a Jeff Sessions Cologne that we
have all kinds of stuff I mean anyone
can come in here and what is this oh
right
this is a doctor giving a thing a
prostate exam to do to the Oscar
right there because we're just too
crappy
this this brings back so many memories
you think about how many shows we've
done and how much many weird ideas we've
had we build them and they end up in
this room and that's pretty
inspirational but is this something
you're actually is this something you're
eating here bill we might you might what
do you mean you might what is it
it says pop-tarts yes aw root beer float
was that was for a pro prop oh so no
one's eating these anymore okay no I
don't think those sold well you get the
idea this is the proper room bill a lot
of memories you've been with me since
when 93 93 the beginning yeah pretty
amazing it's been a long crazy trip
hasn't it it's been amazing yeah yeah do
you ever just sit here with all the
props late at night and they sort of
start talking to you oh no okay no like
they don't come to life at night and try
and Murr you know they don't do that
okay well again this was a sad interview
bill it was nice talking to you built
all he's the hero of this story this is
the prop room stage 15 Warner Brothers
you got to come by and check this out in
person cuz it's it's pretty sweet tweet
yo this is the conan 360 live pre-show
what's that what's that what's up
presented by AT&T and Conan just
something really special every year he
passes out these these figures these pop
figures that Funko has made and they're
exclusive for comic-con so we have the
spider-man pop figure right there
spider-man yeah another web singing
minute edition so every audience member
gets one of these people go crazy for
these like there's people waiting
outside in the lobby trying to like buy
these off of audience members that did
get into this I saw a grown man truck a
small shower for one of these it's come
on the White House all right it's a
white Walker coating here give her a
quick swift karate chop to the neck so
go bottom and this one is the flash it's
real quick real quick flash a little bit
longer in there people want to see these
86 this is the
in addition Conan pop Figgy there's only
500 of these so you know what that means
it costs something boom the mono Conan
yeah here's and they make these special
for Conan show it's cool the audience
members go home with something it's a
new one every night that they have to go
home with so that's is uh
check those out online for people
selling for a very extravagant prices
and Chris and I who will be in front of
that Panera Bread Hawk are our bootleg
versions of these which is a bunch of
painted towels yeah a bunch of stick
figures a Jew and then I filled the
paper with mache
now even though we're gonna get a look
at the people that make us look good
Conan took a tour of his digital
department on the Warner Bros lot and
we're gonna take a 360 look at that hey
Conan O'Brien here and this is the live
360 pre-show this is kind of interesting
we are now in my Warner Brothers Studio
but what we're gonna do is walk from the
stage over to digital digital is where
it happens let's do that now and now we
are entering the digital world isn't
this amazing you can see various digital
Awards
that we've won that are unrecognizable
to me there's webbie's and it's an Emmy
there I recognise an Emmy and then this
just looks like they took it from a car
I don't know what that means
hey Digital gang you're all on 360 360
live pre-show you're working on our
website right now
team Co how's it going a lot of clicks
and who's drinking this tay hava
black t whose have bleh why do you have
this much to hahvah is there any reason
for that this is a lot of Tejada what I
like to do is I get iced tea and then I
use the empty glass bottle as a water
bottle because I do my spending too much
don't want to hear any more anyway hello
how's it going over there what are you
working on social plan for comic-con
means nothing to me I don't understand
it I know that you guys do a very good
job is it okay that I essentially don't
understand digital is that okay
is it all right that I I mean the
simplest be honest here why do I have to
know I'm just Conan and then your job is
to grind me up and turn me into little
qubits and send it out into the ethernet
right yeah the more if you don't know
very good
what's a your name into the 360 world
Tory okay don't be confused and Tory
what are you working on okay all right
okay back into the website oh what's
this here what are you doing this is a
hand lotion why do you have the handles
if you have dry skin yeah I have extreme
I get headaches look at that look at my
it doesn't that look like a mummy's hand
that was just taken out of a tomb after
3,000 years the quivering I'm adding
how's it going in the digital realm okay
you guys all say that like you're
prisoners prisoners of war in North
Vietnam it's going well we are being
treated well let's talk digital for a
second you guys work in the coolest most
cutting-edge part of the business why do
you have a stapler why would this be
even necessary
no one's needed one of these in like 40
years why do you guys have one let's get
rid of it why do you have tape
you shouldn't have tape everything is
unnecessary here this is oh my god spry
what is this dental defense system why
does this even here whose is this do we
know who this is this should go this
should just be gone why do we have a
Mennonite farmer step forward why is it
you look like you just came from a barn
raising why are you here do you even
understand the Internet
I do you do the tech but that's all you
but why do you look like you just walked
away from your butter churn to join us
these are the creative young minds that
are keeping me relevant or so they tell
me funny when I go out in the real world
15 year olds throw rotten apples at me
so good job everybody
I know that really do they're doing an
amazing job I kid I make a joke but
we're going to comic-con and it couldn't
work without the digital team or so I'm
told
I honestly don't know
we probably have enough I could probably
sign off now but first I'm gonna pour
out Erin Blair it's teh hava juice do we
have a perfect thank you for helping
because this is way too much to have a
juice for one man to have that right
there with my favorite video because
they're the reason we're here so ha ha
ha Coenen 360 live free shots been great
hanging out with you guys all week yes a
show tomorrow and I'm tonight's on the
show
Conan welcomes the cast of Game of
Thrones you got a chance to say hello
yeah to Quinlan she was amazing she was
very tall it was so awesome and also bet
to see Dumbledore yeah he was really
cool rock star Janet Varney and whole
cast of choice call deal of Oak Island
Cody
that's what season they're a lot of C's
man and we've been your host man Chris
red you can find me online rest set it
on Twitter and Chris red is on Instagram
I need the father was probably ash
please follow him
I don't need it I'm pretty comfortable
with most out of 200 chris has a show
coming out on Netflix called disjointed
this August 25th right fine available
then see you gotta check out that show
he's honestly very funny in that and
he's with the friend of ours Betsy Sudar
who's yeah what's up bets thank you for
tuning in to Kona 360 live brought to
you by AT&T our good friends I'm go get
a free phone later probably not this is
great man yeah person to host a sweet
we are Red Storm check us out for you in
our lair for around the world and we'll
see you later
enjoy the show thanks Ruthie thanks play
[Music]